oh my God ladies and gentlemen I'm I'm
so excited to cover this story dude the
ending of this story is crazy it's next
level and I was oh my God I'm sorry
let's calm down y'all let's calm down
let's cover this story okay check this
out so what this does is this opens up
on just like an alternate Earth and
Superman on this alternate Earth is
getting absolutely pummeled now there's
this this like disembodied voice that
comes out of nowhere right and it says
can you still hear me Cal or has that
ability faded too and the response to
this Superman is I can hear you and this
person says good then know that I'm
coming do you want to run away and the
response of Superman is I'm not running
and the other person says of course not
they never run only for us to find out
it's Ultraman son now here's the thing
that's not even the big reveal that's
not even the big reveal but Ultraman let
me tell you something about Ultraman
right okay look here's the thing y'all
gonna love this so Ultraman comes to a
place called Earth 3. and he basically
leads What's called the crime syndicate
of America so you know how like every
Universe in the DC Multiverse has a
Justice League right like they fight for
good and you know all that kind of cool
stuff the crime syndicate those guys are
dicks but they're amazing so the crime
syndicate is basically an evil justice
league and Earth 3 is a reality where
everything's inverted all the
traditional good guys are bad guys and
all the traditional bad guys are good
guys it's one of the coolest universes
out there in DC Comics Ultraman is the
Superman of Earth 3 who's basically a
villain and what he's been doing is
traveling around the Multiverse and
killing off every Superman he can find
in every Universe it's amazing because
literally after pummeling this Superman
he's like say it cow say your last word
and like he literally says Lois and and
literally ultraman's like there it is
it's always the same and he blasts him
with his heat vision and he's like now
burn dude it's the most dope
I'm responded oh dude I saw that I was
like sun sun man it's absolutely amazing
right so literally he's like done on to
the next and then just lease so what
this does is it switches over to
Jonathan Kent the son of Superman now
here's the thing man I gotta tell y'all
I have been missing out son this story
is like the best thing coming out of
dawn of DC right now dude it is it is
amazing right so like Jonathan Ken is
kind of doing his thing and just sort of
continuing on right like hanging out
with his boyfriend and so on and so
forth folks got all pissed off when it
turned out that Jonathan Ken had a
boyfriend like bro he's a fictional
character with powers of a God that's
the thing you choose to get mad about
like it's just one of the weirdest
things but what ends up happening is
like all these satellites just seemingly
start crashing to the ground out of
nowhere like just falling out of the sky
now the crazy thing here is that
Superman Supergirl all those traditional
Superman characters they're all off
world they're off doing their own thing
whatever it happens to be so Jonathan
Kent is like the only Superman type
character who's here now he does the
traditional super hero thing where like
he travels around grabbing all these
different satellites and trying to keep
them from crashing into Earth it's cool
to see but the other cool thing here is
he actually reaches out to Oracle
Barbara Gordon which is not something
that you normally see usually Barbara
Gordon's deals almost exclusively with
the bat family but because of the fact
that it is all kind of a shared
community and so on it is awesome to see
that little bit of a reference here so
of course Barbara is able to feed him
information that allows him to achieve
his goal of basically stopping all these
satellites from like crashing into
cities and so on and so forth but what
she also says here is that there's
somebody else out there who's moving
around and they're destroying all these
different satellites and it looks like
Jonathan Kent and that person are on a
collision course now here's the other
cool thing that happens too right in
this moment when Jonathan Ken is
traveling around and trying to stop
these satellites he gets like this
momentary experience where this kind of
like inner power sort of surges up now
it's not the first time this has
happened but it's never been explained
and even now we still don't know what
this means we don't know if it's like a
whole new level of power we don't know
if he's gonna transcend the traditional
Superman and we go back to like the
1990s after Superman died and came back
it becomes like the man of energy and
that terrible ass series of stories that
DC was writing back in the day whatever
the case happens to be we don't exactly
know what's gonna happen here but what
we do know is that when he finally makes
his way to the other person that's
traveling around and stopping all these
satellites we end up finding out it's
Val Zod dude thousand is amazing okay
look here's the thing here's a cool
thing right valzad is the leader of the
multiversal Justice League so for those
of you guys who don't know what that is
the way this works is that you have
What's called the house of Heroes so
where you do have a Justice League on
every single Earth the house of Heroes
is where the multiversal Justice League
operates out of they also have Captain
carrot Oh Captain carrot I love Captain
carrot Captain carrots a super bunny I
love Captain Karen he's like one of the
coolest characters ever he's like a
rabbit Superman but you have like all
these different like superheroes didn't
operate out of this place it's one of
the coolest things ever but Val Zod is
one of the most amazing versions of
Superman because when he basically saves
everything he introduces himself to
Jonathan because Jonathan has never
really met valzad before and it's one of
the easy things to miss given the nature
of the DC Multiverse and the superheroes
and so on and so forth it's easy to
forget that Jonathan doesn't really know
anything about the house of Heroes but
it's kind of cool because what ends up
happening is valzad actually ends up
grabbing uh Jonathan and then taking him
to meet Mr terrific now Mr terrific for
those of you guys who aren't familiar is
probably one of the most intelligent
people in the entirety of the DC
Universe right the guy's got like a
genius level intellect but he's also
worked alongside valzad in the in the DC
Comics landscape and so that's the
reason why Val's eye considers him to be
a friend and it's why Jonathan is
brought to valzad as well as them
grabbing uh Lois Lane now the reason why
this happens is because what valzad and
really like this Red Tornado do is they
basically talk to Lois and Jonathan
about how Ultraman is traveling around
the Multiverse and killing different
Supermen now the funny thing about this
is Jonathan knows who Ultraman is and
this goes back to Brian Michael bendis's
run on the Superman comics with the
unity Saga which was like one of the
only good things that bendus wrote but
the thing about this is that Jonathan
was at one point kidnapped by Ultraman
and then in turn held in a volcano now
the idea behind Ultraman doing this with
Jonathan and it was really more Jonathan
just kind of Landing in Earth three
right just kind of like literally
passing through a black hole and ending
up in that reality but Ultraman wanted
to take Jonathan Kim at his own kind of
protege and the reason why is one of the
main differences between Jonathan and
even the main DC Universe Superman as
opposed to Ultraman is that Ultraman
believes that strength is the only thing
that matters now a lot of that goes to
the goes back to the time that he was
raised by the Kents in Earth 3 who were
basically exploiting him and then when
in turn they revealed his origin that he
came from a spaceship he realized they
were simply just using him and then he
left right he literally turned about his
own parents and then took off from
Smallville and then just basically
became a warlord on Earth but the thing
about this is because Jonathan is
familiar with Ultraman he's also aware
of how capable Ultraman is now the other
part of this is that red tornado and
valzad didn't have to deal with what is
quite possibly one of the most dangerous
forces in the entirety of the Multiverse
which is a concerned mom I mean let's be
honest guys right like Ultraman sure
right like the presence Lucifer
Morningstar okay but they have nothing
on like a worried mom because she will
burn reality
a worried and concerned Mom right like
an upset Mama Bear will destroy all
creation for the sake of her child
that's just the way it works and Lois
Lane in particular is the one they have
to contend with and a lot of this is
because Lois does not want to see her
son go off into the Multiverse and
potentially face off against the being
that could kill him but what red toy
tornado does is she reveals a couple
different things the first is she says
that they would not be asking Jonathan
if there was any other possible way but
what they've learned here is that
Ultraman has some kind of device at his
disposal that has the ability to weaken
any version of Kalel across the
Multiverse now the kicker to this is
that the device seems to be restricted
only to people who are Kalel and not
anybody else and so that's why they've
asked Jonathan because Jonathan and
valzad are kind of the exceptions
because yes they are Superman but
they're not different versions they're
not variants of Clark Kent Kalel and so
because of that they're the ones that
really have to respond to this but what
Red Tornado also reveals is that the
Superman the clerk of her Earth was also
destroyed and that's when she reveals
she's an alternate reality version of
Lois Lane and so it's a really cool
Revelation here because what it means is
that it's not the house of Heroes just
asking this question indiscriminately
with no real skin in the game outside of
just seeing that like some alternate
reality versions of Superman are being
destroyed and that's basically it but
it's actually a version of Lois who lost
her own version of Superman so she
understands the true risks that are
going on here now the other big concern
and the reason why it's really more than
just Superman being killed that's the
issue is that what the house of Heroes
has also learned is that whenever
Ultraman shows up to an alternate Earth
he kills that version of Superman and
then leaves because there is no Superman
on that world it's only a matter of time
before that world Falls to any number of
threats that exist out there because
Superman is such a significant player
within the realm of DC Comics that he is
in a lot of ways the first line of
defense and the thing that holds a lot
of villains back from initiating these
worldwide schemes to destroy Earth
whether they're from Earth or not just
because of the power Superman has now
this is a great reference to a story in
DC Comics called the Nail which is
actually a result of what happens when
when there is no Superman on Earth and
how things transpire but the other part
of this and really kind of switching
over to the point when Jonathan Kent
leaves this comes by way of Red Tornado
being able to quite literally look into
the Multiverse and see when it is that
Ultraman jumps the downside to this is
the only time they can see when Ultraman
jumps is after he's killed a superman
but they seemingly are able to pick up
on where it is he's going next and so
the result of this is that when they
find out where he's traveled to they end
up immediately taking off now when they
arrive to this earth it's one of the
coolest moments when they arrive here
Red Tornado seeks out Ultraman she's
able to find him but just a moment
before he flies right through her and
basically rips her in half and then
after that like he just attacks Jonathan
who's standing there with a phantom a
Phantom Zone projector right like a
device that can basically send Ultraman
into limbo right The Phantom Zone kind
of a extra dimensional prison that
people are normally not able to escape
from but when Jonathan Kim's taken out
Ultraman realizes is The Phantom Zone
projector he picks it up and then he
literally pulls in valzad and Red
Tornado and so now it's just Jonathan
and Ultraman now it's one of the cool
moments because in a lot of ways it's
kind of a return to things now that's
what's so interesting about this right
because there was a point in this story
when Jonathan asked valzad why am I the
only Jonathan that you're reaching out
to isn't there any other version of me
that you can grab and the response of
al-zod is no you are unique in the
Multiverse because every version of
Jonathan Kent is the age that you're
supposed to be now the reason why this
is being stated is because of the fact
that remember during Brian Michael
business's run on Superman one of the
things that had happened is that
Jonathan Kent had been taken from from
Superman and Lois and then over time had
basically just been aged up so he's
older than he's actually supposed to be
the only exception to this is the
statement that valzad makes which is
really really cool where he talks about
how there is another reality where there
is an older version of Jonathan Kent but
that universe is overrun with the undead
I.E deceased which is an awesome
reference in this story I love that they
referenced the events of DC's ironically
enough Tom Taylor's writing both of
these so of course he references his own
work and so with valzad and those guys
being sucked into The Phantom Zone what
is it happening is Jonathan Kim blast
Ultraman with his heat vision as
powerful as he possibly can which is
enough to like singe him and destroy the
Phantom Zone projector and then in turn
Ultraman goes back on the offense and
then attacks Jonathan Kent now the funny
thing about this is that he literally
tells Jonathan you're still holding back
you're still not using your full power
you've learned nothing in the time that
we spent together when I was trying to
make you my protege now again despite
the fact that Ultraman was trying to get
Jonathan to cast aside the idea of
compassion and caring considering those
weaknesses there were valuable lessons
to be learned there in the sense that
Jonathan truly was holding back that he
never really seems to have come to the
same realization his father did that
there are more times when you can cut
loose fighting Ultraman is one of those
but Jonathan has another one of these
moments where this kind of mysterious
internal power suddenly flares up and
when that happens this guy cold Cox
Ultraman in the head and beeps on him
like a side of beef dude man he do he
beats his ass and like basically like
pummels this guy into the ground and
then just reverts back to his normal
form right like it's it's cool it's one
of the coolest things not only that we
do get what is quite possibly one of the
most amazing costume changes in the
history of DC Comics because Jonathan
Kent in this all blue Superman suit
looks dope like it looks pretty unmade I
mean come on guys Post in the comments
and tell me how dope this is it looks
awesome but with basically Jonathan Kent
kind of succumbing to the sheer amount
of power that he had to sort of expend
here right almost passing out from it
all that what ends up happening is
Ultraman immediately attacks him and
starts choking him out and he says oh
okay like here's the thing right you
want to play Big Boys you want to play
with the big boys then we can play right
we can do this dance I'm taking you back
to my world I'm dropping you back in
that volcano where you're basically
removed from the influence of the yellow
sun and then I will teach you to become
me I will teach you how to fight I will
force you to fight and I will make you
better than what you are and he says I'm
not gonna kill you John he says but I am
certainly taking this personally I
usually don't bother with the lowest
Lanes but I'll make an exception on your
world man man what's coming is crazy
anybody who's read this story man I know
it's gonna be cursed social science
right he says he says I will make your
Lois suffer and then this voice out of
nowhere says no you won't it turns out
they're on the Injustice Earth Sun and
Injustice Superman breaks the neck of
Ultraman on the spot dude magnification
it's Injustice and Justice Superman's
son Ultraman had no idea who he was
messing with man because Injustice super
wanna dude this guy's so overpowered
it's not even funny son so like
literally like when this happens
Injustice Superman sees like Jonathan
Ken sitting there and he's like are you
okay and Jonathan's like you killed him
and the response of Injustice Superman
is you have your mother's eyes why does
that matter check the comments that's
pinned on this video to watch the
Injustice playlist and to see why that
matters because man that story tells you
what happens when the Joker kills Lois
Lane with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching I will catch you
all later peace